l'histoire mais je sais c'est très
marrant salue monsieur lucas alors
comment ça se passe mon casting bien ça
se passe bien c'est au vu des bons
acteurs pour mon film je veux des nains
dans des robots t'oublie pas des nains
dans des robots ouais mais c'est pas
évident les acteurs comprennent pas tout
vu que ça se passe dans l'espace
les personnages c'est d'être atteint
très bien c'est bien et je fais un beau
casting j'ai fait le film dans l'espace
je fais un film dans l'espace et dans 20
ans je mets tout massacré avec des
images de synthèse au casting chewbacca
candidats 73 bonjour à chantilly
présentez vous je m'appelle traver
bottleneck je suis comédien anglais de
formation classique théâtre âgées
peuvent réciter un poème de lord byron
où vous jouez la mort de roméo avec le
foulard rouge pour faire le sang non je
crois vous connaissez votre texte alors
justement il doit ya voir l'erreur je
n'ai reçu que des voyages non oui c'est
ça c'est décrit en fait c'est mais où
est la profondeur du personnage je sais
pas c'est décrit en fait
mais pourquoi elles crient ils mal la
voiture marche pas les pressions de trop
cher j'en ai dit oui écrit oui mais
chewbacca oui écrit mais comment
voulez-vous par exemple faire passer une
émotion sous jacente si la situation
devient trop insoutenable et que la
catharsis et of the cape rouge et bien
faire les cris effet sur la feuille non
monsieur non trevor bateau de la grippe
a il vit vous connaissez la devise de
shakespeare non d'abord des mots ensuite
des mots et enfin des mots vous êtes sûr
c'est pas si on y va à kate sont allés
plus vite
non non non ok faits décrits au revoir
monsieur on est vraiment dans une
impasse excusez moi alors j'ai rêvé ou
non mais je croyais qu'on n'avait plus
du tout donc venez c'est très bien entre
et présentez vous
bah je m'appelle peter may you et je
suis infirmier est c'est parti pour les
cris par dont les cris non non mais moi
en fait je travaille juste dans
l'immeuble et je voulais vous dire cris
dit qu'elle sorte de cri a créé des
extraterrestres humanoïdes à four de la
race des bouquets qui serait une sorte
de croisement entre un ours un lion et
un labrador j'en ai marre d'être ici
cris voilà parfait je t'engage et je
démissionne et c'est ainsi que je joue
bach est devenu un personnage
emblématique de star wars avant que jupp
heynckes ne viennent tout détruire
en tout cas on aimerait des chaussettes